[Music]
wall street english once sold private
tutoring sessions to chinese students
keen to improve through extra study
[Music]
now it's one of more than one thousand
companies forced to close their doors
following sweeping new education
regulations tutoring companies can no
longer teach compulsory school subjects
teach during school hours not earn a
profit
thousands of foreign tutors like
catherine peterson have suddenly found
themselves redundant the american has
taught english and critical thinking
skills in china for five years this is
going to impact the industry a lot and
especially now with covet it's so hard
for
foreigners to come into the country too
i think it might mean a huge downsizing
of the industry
many parents invested in tutors to help
their children boost their results in
hyper-competitive exams known as gao cow
that they need to pass to get into
universities but many say china's
tutoring industry that was once worth an
estimated 140 billion dollars is now
decimated
chen yusha lost her job as an
administrator in one of china's biggest
tutoring companies and is now
this industry was booming but it put a
lot of pressure on parents because extra
tutoring is not
chinese government hopes its crackdown
on private tutoring will reduce the cost
of raising a child and ease pressure on
families china's birth rate is slowing
and authorities are desperately trying
to encourage couples to have more
children but analysts say this isn't the
only goal authorities also want to
encourage investment in more innovative
areas of china's i.t industries to
create greater competition with
high-tech companies in the west
amazon is investing heavily in space
technology elon musk is conquering mars
but those um
those it giants in china they're making
money of parents anxieties but some
worry that the government ban may just
lead to a black market in private
tutoring just because the government has
banned or is trying to cut back on a
certain kind of education i don't think
that will stop parents from trying to
pursue it
the government says it's offering
support to thousands of people affected
by the measures but that may not be
enough to help all of those reeling from
the shock of seeing their teaching
career in china suddenly at an end
katrina u al jazeera beijing